- [Voiceover] Hello, everyone.
So what I'd like to do
here and in the following
few videos is talk about how you take the
partial derivative of
vector valued functions.
So the kind of thing I have in mind
will be a function with
a multi-variable input,
so this specific example have
a two variable input, p and s.
You could think of that
as a two-dimensional space
as the input or just two separate numbers.
And its output will be three-dimensional.
The first component, p
squared minus s-squared.
The y component will be s times t.
And that z component
will be t times s-squared
minus s times t-squared,
minus s times t-squared.
And the way that you
compute a partial derivative
of a guy like this, is actually
relatively straight-forward.
If you're to just guess
what it might mean,
you'll probably guess right.
It will look like partial
of v with respect to
one of its input variables,
and I'll choose t
with respect to t.
And you just do it component-wise,
which means you look at each component
and you with a partial derivative to that
'cause each component is just a normal
scaler valued function.
So you go up to the top one and you say
t-squared looks like a variable,
as far t is concerned,
and this derivative is 2t.
But s-squared looks like a constant,
so its derivative is zero.
S times t, when s looks like a constant
and when t looks like a variable,
has a derivative of s.
Then t times s-squared,
when t's the variable
and s is the constant, just
looks like that constant,
which is s-squared
minus s times t-squared.
So now a derivative of t-squared is 2t
and that constant s stays in.
So that two times s times t.
And that's how you compute it,
probably relatively straightforward.
The way you do it with
respect to s is very similar,
but where this gets fun
and where this gets cool
is how you interpret the
partial derivative, right,
how you interpret this
value that we just found.
And what that means
depends a lot on how you
actually visualize the function.
So what I'll go ahead
and do in the next video
and in the next few ones, is talk about
visualizing this function.
It'll be as a parametric surface
and three-dimensional space.
That's why I got my
grapher program out here
and I think you'll find
there's actually a very
satisfying understanding
of what this value means.